[Music]
I'm standing in front of one of the tens
of thousands of testing booths all
across China that are closed at the
Heyday of covet zero basically you have
to take a test every day or every other
day and now overnight China has scrapped
that requirement
[Music]
for nearly three years China championed
a set of draconian rules to completely
Stamp Out the virus
so its decision in early December to
scrap almost all of them took many by
surprise
but instead of celebrations many cities
have come to a standstill as the country
is hit by a huge wave of infections
here's what China's reopening looks like
on the ground and why China may find it
challenging to learn to live with covet
normally on a Friday afternoon I could
barely stand here without getting bumped
by all the people walking by me but ever
since China lifted covet zero
restrictions pretty abruptly
nobody's really going out and that's
because people are being infected so
people are either sick at home or scared
to go outside
because China's vaccines have lower
efficacy rates compared to the West
and the vaccination rate particularly
among the elderly is low
nearly three years of mass testing and
snap lockdowns meant fewer people got
covered and natural immunity against the
virus isn't High
now with people worried about venturing
outside businesses are taking a hit
lunch hour and I'm walking around this
food court employees are standing behind
the counter fiddling with their
smartphones because there's no business
with many customers and employees sick
people's livelihoods are at risk that's
a drag on the country's sluggish economy
which is already going through its worst
downturn in more than three decades
but there is one exception to this
pharmacies there's a Brisk trade in
basic cough fever medicine although
they're sold out of antigen tests and
there are a lot of empty shelves with
people having cleaned them all out to
take care of themselves at home which is
where most people are now dealing with
their relatively mild coveted symptoms
but if those symptoms get worse China's
Health System may not be prepared
for nearly three years the government
has focused its resources on eradicating
covid not living with it so China lacks
the infrastructure to cope with the tens
of millions of people who may be
infected
so Beijing has opened up hundreds of
fever clinics to cope with the influx of
new patients so there's been a real push
to get people not to come to hospitals
and not to call the emergency ambulance
services unless they have very serious
symptoms
authorities are also sending another
clear message
that life needs to return to normal
so some braver residents are venturing
out as people are encouraged to go back
to the gym movie theaters and start
traveling there's a lot of Hope here
that come this spring if the cases have
washed over China maybe we can be back
to uh business as normal and and into a
new post-coveted reality